this episode of the minimalists is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck this
podcast has bad words
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists today we're going to
talk about
alternative living options ryan it
sounds like we're opening up a center
it does doesn't it the alternative
living options center i'm trying to
think of the most like
crazy living you know arrangement
like you and i could do if mariah moved
in with you and then bex moved in with
me
and we were roommates
that's not unappealing
actually yeah it is but well because
mariah is in la 100 of the time
right right you would never get any
alone time yeah that's true well
so there's a bunch of different things
we can talk about although we have
christopher kelly here from nourish
balance thrive chris thank you for being
here
well thank you for having me i
appreciate it now there are reasons that
you're here we'll get in
to that but at first i wanted to have do
an episode sort of about communal
living but i thought maybe that wasn't
all-encompassing enough because people
had questions about throuples about
combined families about
long-term singlehood about nomadic
living
and a whole lot more and so i think what
happens here and the reason i found this
topic to be so appealing is we think
that there's a way that we're
supposed to live and
let me give you first a 30-second
overview of chris i've known chris we've
been friends
for i don't know five years or so now
and uh
i often say chris is one of the few
people well he he and i have some of the
best podcasts that we never record
that's right on the phone yeah we just
have a phone call and um
we'll talk for an hour or something i'm
like man i wish we would have recorded
this and now he's here we can actually
record it yeah but chris helped me out
with a lot of health things early on
when i was starting to figure out some
of my
my health problems how did you find
chris when you were uh looking for some
help with your health stuff maybe
through ben greenfield i'm not entirely
sure
okay but that might have been it um and
and so when i stumbled across chris and
he helped me through a whole lot of
i had mercury poisoning and a bunch of
other stuff that was going on
all the things i think yes yeah yeah uh
c diff etc
and and chris really helped me navigate
the the beginning of that uh
nourishbalancethrive.com if you've got
health issues you want to talk about
that we're not talking about health
stuff today
although we're talking about a component
that directly affects our health
i think so it might be the most
important and hardest problem i've had
to try and solve you know
oh yeah so let's talk about the problem
in fact uh you wrote down here that
you're a zookeeper for
obligatory gregarious homo sapiens
what does that mean i think this is a
good segue into ancestral health right
so
what i meant by that was imagine you are
a zookeeper
and some new species of upright bipedal
ape shows up at your zoo
and you've got to figure out how you're
going to look after them right so what
are you going to do you're going to keep
them in separate enclosures
are you going to put them all in
together are you going to make them sign
a contract
saying that they'll never put their
genitals near another ape
are you going to feed them subway and
pizza hut
or are you going to feed them what i
mean what are you going to do like how
are you going to design that zoo right
like you have infinite degrees of
freedom
it reminds me of this place ryan in ohio
where they used to have that chimp or he
would smoke and eat
like candy bars all the time yeah that
was so sad and i wouldn't do that
right right exactly and this is what
they did do look up the story of guy the
gorilla
was a gorilla that showed up at london
zoo and in the beginning they didn't
really know how to keep gorillas in
captivity
and they allowed the the guests at the
zoo to actually feed guy
and eventually he died of cardiovascular
disease and diabetes just like humans do
oh wow right through that they learned a
lot about how to
look after gorillas in captivity and
they don't do that anymore right and you
look at
how they keep gorillas in captivity it's
amazing we were at san diego zoo
looking at their gorillas recently it's
absolutely incredible the enclosure is
so much thought has gone into that
enclosure and the diet
it's not exactly like the diet a gorilla
would eat in the wild but it's
really close right you can go to the
local supermarket and reconstruct a diet
that's really close to what the gorilla
would eat in the wild
now my argument is that we should be
doing the same as as humans right we've
been on this planet millions of years
our ancestors
uh walking around under the same light
dark cycle
uh anatomically modern for probably
three hundred thousand years
and then everything changed you know 10
000 years ago
and then in particular about 10 000
years ago because of agriculture
because of the birth of agriculture yeah
that changed like once we became
sedentary that
that changed everything by sedentary i
mean we stopped becoming
hunter-gatherers that just wandered the
savannah
hunting and gathering and became
sedentary we settled down
we started growing we domesticated fire
and then plants
and then animals and that changed
everything but of course
those things domesticated argue us as
would say right you could argue that
couldn't you that you know did we
domesticate fire
or did it domesticate us right so an
interesting question but
when you look at the last even 10 20
years
technology has changed as beyond
recognition like artificial light at
night is a good example
social media is a really good example
and it would seem that
these changes are not great for our
overall health
and and they're not great in ways that
we don't notice right away yeah and
especially
what i've noticed the younger we are the
the more
i won't say immune we are to these
external stimuli
but the more resilient we seem to be but
over time
for whatever reason and i'm sure you
have some hypotheses around it
these things affect us negatively and
you in your practice
at nourishbalancethrive.com you have
lots of people who come to you because
conventional medicine sort of broke down
wasn't able to find the answers for them
in fact it wasn't even about finding
solutions they couldn't even identify
what the problem
is right and a lot i've heard you say
that a lot of these problems that we
deal with now
there there isn't like we get so caught
up in silver bullet thinking
and what you'd like to do is sort of
take a more holistic approach
and i think part of that holistic
approach has to do with
with our living arrangements that's why
i wanted to title this one
unusual living arrangements because it's
unusual in the sense that society has
sort of prescribed
something to us and by the way i do want
to dive deep into your own communal
living
you you have a communal living situation
we want to dive deep into that on the
maximum episode but first chris
i want to talk about why you're here
today
because well um
it feels like we've been prescribed this
way of living and what you're saying is
that prescription
while it may work for some people it's
not natural
well i'm natural like i'm kind of scared
of that word you know like it conjures
up
thoughts of the naturalistic fallacy you
know okay well it's not birth from
nature how about that
it may not be optimal okay and
personally i didn't realize there were
choices
you know like i just conformed to the
societal expectations
and then only once i had kids like
that's when the really hits the fan
is when you have kids you realize oh
this doesn't actually work very well you
know
two people at the nucleus and then
however many dependents orbiting like
charged particles
we call this a nuclear family it doesn't
work very well now did it work
previous to kids and and only the
introduction of kids
made it not work or was it the
introduction of kids that made you say
huh maybe the whole thing doesn't really
work yeah i think that's a good point i
think that the kids are the straw that
broke the camel's back right it kind of
sharpens it and you're like oh actually
this really doesn't work
yeah yeah well um so
where did this all sort of where did
this idea start that
of the nuclear family well i think it's
quite modern you know there's a really
nice piece in the atlantic
i read recently i think it was like the
1950s in the us
at least the nuclear family wasn't a
thing before the 1950s
and it was an idea it was a boom time
where it could possibly work you know
where you had dad went off to work on
his own and
mom stayed home and looked after the
kids and of course now it's
not really possible in silicon valley if
you want to buy a starter home in
mountain view then probably both of the
parents need to be working a full-time
job at apple or facebook or google or
something
in order to be able to pay the mortgage
for you know a two million dollar
starter home so i don't i think even now
you know this is our go together we're
from dayton ohio right two million
dollars you're like
the richest man in the county if you
have a two million dollar house
yeah that's like oh seriously there are
like two million dollar starter homes
for sure
and so there's like maybe this moment in
time in the 1950s where the nuclear
family was an option it could work
but ever since are you arguing that it
never works it doesn't sound to me like
that's it either because
it seems to me that like that's the trap
that we get caught up in
whereas it's supposed to be one way
as opposed to yes there is a for lack of
a better term natural way
in which we uh we evolved to become
humans
uh an evolutionary way of living but of
course we've
we've changed we've improved upon our
lives we have electricity and we all
think that's for the better
and if we don't think it is then none of
us
that i know are are you know completely
doing without these things right
and so i'm wondering if um
i look at these these these living
situations these these arrangements
it's not to say the nuclear family is
bad
or wrong or anything like that but
it's not to say that the other way is
even right or better
it's it's to say what is appropriate for
you
yeah i think that's i think that's right
i mean so what how people make the
nuclear family work is they
purchase the additional social support
that would have previously come from the
community right so people hire
you know a wet nurse a postpartum
jeweler a therapist
a mentor a tutor in all these different
things that normally would have been
part of your tribe now
they're hiring a community i would say
so i mean don't you think interesting
yeah never thought of that that way
yeah that's a great perspective yeah
like they're hiring a daycare
yeah exactly i mean even teachers as
well
yeah i mean certainly when they're young
you're not really teaching you're just
doing babysitting right
right yeah yeah so so but
it has to go back before that as well
where we started to believe
that that um there was a
you know i don't know if it's a
puritanical sort of way of thinking
but whatever it is there is
there's something here where we've been
forced into believing we have to live a
particular way
and i don't think i don't want the
reaction to that
to be well no that's wrong here's the
right answer
i think what we're talking about here
today is hey here are some other options
yeah perhaps so we're going to get into
that i want to dive deep into chris's
story as well but i thought we would
start with some
questions from our audience we have a
question here from gwen
in athens ohio how should i go about
combating
roommates or friends of roommates who
steal my material items such as food
or money or self-care so chris let's
let's rephrase gwen's question here
basically say how do i appropriately set
boundaries with
the people in my community or in my home
or whatever to ensure those boundaries
are
not crossed you want to prevent people
from stealing obviously
property damage but also just tense
living
situations right um now you live in a
can you talk a bit about your maybe your
communal situation
so we've experimented with a number of
different configurations over the past
year
ranging from like a time segmented
type arrangement where for a few days a
week we're living
with another family so i've got two kids
uh one who's a girl who's seven
and a boy who's three and we've spent
time living under the same roof
with another couple who have kids of
similar ages
uh mm-hmm we've lived with a a number of
different families but
i think they've all had two kids you
know about the same ages now what have
you learned from living with these
different families because
you uh gwen's question here is you
basically have introduced roommates what
what
we in our today society would say
roommate it's different from that
but that's how you even have to classify
it it's almost it's it's euphemistic
right
there was a time not too long ago when
gay couples used to have to say they had
roommates
as opposed to having uh a partner or a
husband or
and and so now you are trying these sort
of experiments
uh with other families living together
um
how did you why did you start doing this
i think the kids were actually the main
driver
i did a pocket interview with peter gray
who you might might know
his uh he's got a really great book
called free to learn okay
and peter talked about the common word
is unschooling
yes i don't really like that term peter
doesn't like it either because it
focuses on what you're not doing
versus what you are doing so perhaps a
better description
is non-coercive self-directed learning
meaning you're trusting the kids to find
the best learning opportunity
on their own without you doing much of
anything and
in order for that to work you need older
kids right i don't care how old your kid
is you need an older kid
because the older kid is like the
scaffolding that helps the younger kid
up to the next level so you're not doing
the teaching the older kids are doing
the teaching
you know so i've seen this happen
firsthand where you've got an older kid
that can read
and they're looking at words on a screen
or a piece of paper and they're telling
the younger kid what they say so the
older kid is actually teaching
the younger kid even though the older
kid doesn't know what they're doing yeah
and in that teaching
he or she is also learning through the
problem you learn so much more by
teaching than
than just about any other way exactly
and so the problem is like you can't do
that with just two kids
right like you need more kids than that
and so the question then becomes where
do you get more kids
now we live in a very rural area where
most of the houses are on very large
lots
and so there are some kids around in the
neighborhood but not
enough and so we needed to do something
to bring more kids in and
and that's exactly what we've been able
to do and it's been great
well let's talk a bit a bit more about
that um when you say it's been great it
sounds like you've lived with several
different families
ex explain that yeah so we've done a
couple of different things we've had
people living in our house we so we live
in quite a small house it's about
1200 square foot and you know that's
not very much space when you've got two
families living under the same roof
we've also done other things like having
people bring on a trailer like these
i don't know if you've seen them but
these travel trailers are tremendous
value for money you can get
like a house that's nicer than our house
for
you know 20 000 or something and you can
move it you can just roll it on to so
we're lucky that we live on quite a
large property
we've had people bring on a trailer and
use that as a sort of separate space
from the main house that can definitely
get a little bit crazy at times
and and so how do you navigate these
relationships because these
different people have different desires
different ones different preferences
different hobbies
uh different levels of tolerance and and
different desires
how do you navigate all of that well i
think you start by
having similar value systems right so
ancestral health is
super important to us and it gives us
some guiding principles
that we operate by and like finding
people that share those values like i
could live with you
it'd be great because i know you eat the
same food you go to bed at the same time
i think we could we share a lot of
things in common and so
it's not that much work to try and close
the gap you know
um so i heard once a lawyer told me that
that sometimes a case will go to
mediation and the judge will just refuse
to do anything they won't try and close
the gap because it's just too big
like there's too much distance between
the two sides and they say
go away just go sue yourself you know go
sue each other because this is not a gap
i can close
and i think the same is true with like
communal living like you need to
find people that share your value system
so that whenever conflict does arise
there's like not that much of a gap to
close and so
and that is indeed what we've been doing
so all of the people we've lived with
have had very similar value systems ryan
it sounds like
obviously the the thing that um
the best way to deal with conflict
within the house to get back to gwen's
question here
is to screen the roommates beforehand
right right i think back to
relationships that i've had
whether friendship or into intimate
relationships
quite often it's simply a screening
problem because chris said like
we don't have the same values of course
there's good with that greater gap
means there's going to be greater
tension between the two of us yeah
yeah i mean when it comes to gwen's
question i would you know ask her
is there a way to close that gap with
with her roommates and with her
roommates friends it sounds like
yeah um if it's not possible
i mean she could certainly do things
like i don't know when i had roommates i
would
lock my door um i didn't it didn't get
to the point where i had a
where i had to get like my own mini
fridge because uh that gap
with the particular roommate you know
who i'm talking about oh yeah
um i will uh not name him to
not shame him publicly yeah exactly
but you know if i couldn't move out and
if i couldn't afford it to have moved
out like it would have come to that
situation where i would have had to
spend like a couple hundred bucks to get
my own mini fridge
right um yeah so uh yeah if the gap is
too
large gwen she's gotta move out
it's really rough it's very different
from my situation like everyone we've
lived with
has been tremendously respectful like
overly cautious of anything you know
what it's like when you
move in with a partner and it's kind of
intimidating right like you're moving
into their space and you tread really
lightly and you're just very respectful
yeah that's more similar to my situation
versus
living in college with a bunch of
[ __ ] roommates that are like fine
about
taking your food and yeah like that's a
very different situation i think
so but even then you have you have
conflict right and so
there'll be times where maybe you don't
agree on a parenting thing
yeah and how does that work out uh that
actually ended
one uh one yeah you're right like here
we go now we're getting into the drama
the juicy stuff yeah i thought so i
don't have a parenting style
um that's actually peter gray talked
about that in my podcast as well like
hunter-gatherers don't do parenting and
they don't do teaching either
and you know i've read some really good
books on this alison gopnik the
carpenter and the gardener is a really
good one
and i love that metaphor it's like so
relevant for
dealing with complex systems you know
wearing carpentry you measure twice and
you cut once and it's like building a
dining room table and it's very obvious
when the job is done
and you know you test to see if it
wobbles and all this stuff and then
maybe you make some
you know slight refinements and in the
end you've got this perfectly crafted
piece of furniture
whereas in gardening it's mostly about
keeping the weeds out and just creating
an environment for the
for the plants to flourish and you never
really know what you're going to get you
know i mean of course you know what
seeds you put in the ground but you
don't really know what's going to grow
right and so what alison gottnick is
arguing is that parenting is more like
gardening and less like carpentry but a
lot of people they treat it like
carpentry and that
in the beginning i thought i don't care
you know it's fine if like if you want
to do helicopter parenting go ahead and
helicopter
but and you know i don't have a style so
i should be compatible with any style
but you're right it like
once they start helicoptering your kids
it's like oh [ __ ] like i can't handle
this and so that actually did end
one relationship so give me examples of
of helicoptering
what does that look like in in the real
world uh
i mean it looks exactly what it sounds
like it it's you
you you're literally hovering over the
child micromanaging their every move
and the way would like i know it's
happening even if i'm not paying
attention
is like i would hear the kid's name over
and over again like over and over again
you're like wait why is
why is the person's using the kid's name
over and over again
it's because they're constantly trying
to direct them towards the next
it's control yeah it's overly
controlling now what about that control
is so appealing to us
i don't know it's like i think one thing
i think is going on in silicon valley is
people are really struggling with
purpose
you know they do you know like there's
this kind of standing joke that the
the brightest minds in the world are all
working in silicon valley getting people
to click on stuff right
yeah all these people with phds and
stuff like just getting people to click
on stuff
and it's it's not it's not really
scratching people's itch you know it's
not like a great purpose and
i think it's a really common thing for
people to either quit their job
or you know this is what they do as a
hobby like they go all in on parenting
you know like yes
it becomes a new obsession yeah exactly
i think a lot of the helicopter
parenting too probably spawns from good
intentions
you know like maybe you're just trying
to protect your kid from not getting
hurt
and there is a there's a balance there
right but yeah if you're constantly
hovering over them you're not allowing
them to flourish themselves
yeah exactly exactly good intentions and
bad ideas jonathan heights book the
coding of the american mind explains the
whole thing very well i think
yeah and i think if we we back up and
remove ourselves from even the parenting
situation
the same thing can happen with roommates
or or
significant others spouses whatever we
can become
helicopter partners we can become you
know helicopter roommates
and and it quickly becomes an untenable
situation
and so it's fascinating to me when we're
talking about communal
living really what you're talking about
isn't a traditional
commune necessarily but it's maybe an
iteration
of that what do you mean by commune well
what do you what what image is that
conjurer when i say commune
uh it conjures up images wild wild
country that was actually i lied i said
i don't watch tv we did watch that on
there
yes it was really good i really enjoyed
that so yeah i think of gurus
like it scares the hell at me you know
like somebody a boss like
no but it sounds to me like often those
intentions of
because here's the thing we hear about
wild wild country or we hear about
nexium or whatever these these cults
right and there are so many that you
don't hear about because they're
actually just communes that are working
fine and there isn't some sex-crazed
leader who is making the news it just
happens to be
that they're we hear about the salacious
stuff right
and so we hear about when people are
drinking kool-aid and killing themselves
and or
or joining some sort of cult that
castrates
each other or whatever it is that stuff
makes the news
you know it doesn't make the news four
families decide to live together happily
exactly that's happily ever after it's
not a great news story is it
no and so um i know do you see this
evolving
over time as you get acclimated with
different families or whatever do you
see a
a larger group forming out of this
potentially well that's an interesting
question is that how much is enough
this uh is a very interesting question
yeah we've yet to figure out what the
ideal number is i know that things get
way better and my motivation to go find
the others goes
exponentially down as we add more people
so even one other couple and their kids
is so much better than just the nuclear
family in my opinion
how many uh families are living on your
property right now so at the moment
so we're in a relationship with another
couple that's going really well and
they've got
two kids who are 11 and just turned
seven
and then we've got another neighbor who
has a four-year-old girl who recently
put a trailer
on our property and she's more like sort
of the time segmented thing you know
where she'll come for a couple of days a
week
cool and that's i mean so far so good
like it's it's really new but
so far so good awesome i want to talk
about your sleeping situation
on the maximal episode but we have uh we
have some more to get into
gwen i'm going to send you a copy of the
minimalist rule book
because one thing we didn't talk about
but it should be self-evident at this
point
is boundaries now the first boundary is
before you even let the roommate
into the house right until you
the first boundary is not coming to an
agreement with someone who has
complete opposite values with you you
know you're setting yourself
up for discontent for quote unquote
failure
for tension etc uh property damage
whatever like there's going to be all
kinds of
of things you don't want to get involved
in but even then like ryan and i have
the same values
we don't always agree on things in fact
he and i have lived together before
we've had different preferences
and sometimes that just dictates i think
what what
really helped ryan and i live together
was kind of what chris was saying is
like we
we didn't just tolerate each other we
respected each other's
desires yes and in that respect
even if i don't completely understand it
i can completely appreciate
you know the way that you live and vice
versa you're not harming me or anyone
else yeah we were totally
capable of telling each other if
something was bugging us or something
our preferences were being stepped on
maybe yeah it was very simple to just
have a conversation and
i mean that might just spawn from i
think we have an exceptional
an exceptional relationship in that
sense where like we can deliver
the truth to each other in a way
even if it sounds negative like we don't
take it negatively we just kind of take
it for what it is
yes and uh yeah i mean that's i think
that's
unfortunately a rare thing in
relationships but i think the closer
people can get to that in their
relationships to not be offended when
someone's like hey i'd really appreciate
it if you
x y or z um yeah that would create some
better living situations for sure yeah i
found five words that are really useful
for me as well um would you be willing
to
would you be willing to shut up
but instead of like hey man how come you
always leave your uh
salt crumbs on the counter yeah hey
would you be willing to clean those up
yeah it just it this not a patronizing
way but hey
you know would you be willing to and
those have disarmed so many arguments
in my life but also shows a just a
common respect and i think another way
to show respect is to set boundaries up
so
we have the minimalist rule book it's 16
rules for living with
less you can download it for free over
at theminimalists.com
rulebook also the audiobook version is
available there as well
or you can get the free ebook there just
download it the minimalists.com
rulebook ryan what time is it you know
what time it is it is time for our
lightning
round where we answer your text messages
you can text your questions and comments
to
area code 937-202-4654 yes indeed
so during the lightning round chris
you're familiar with this this is where
we do our best to answer questions the
short shareable less than 140 character
response we put the text to these
minimal maxims in the show notes so
people can copy and share our pithy
answers on social media
if they'd like oh and you can find all
of our minimal maxims in one place now
minimal
maxims maxims.com i love like getting
random tweets
with things that i've said and they
quote me and i'm like oh yeah i did say
that like that was good
[Laughter]
they're all in the show notes so you can
copy them like that's a genius quote who
came up with oh that was me
thank god for the website because i
would not remember all of them yeah
we got a question here from eric all
right uh are there countries tribes
societies where unusual living
arrangements for example communal living
throuples combined families long-term
singlehood nomadic living isn't actually
unusual how happy are these people with
these arrangements
what are the pros and cons of these
arrangements okay chris so
there's three questions here in the
lightning round that's what we do during
the lightning round it's actually our
longest segment
yeah strangely um so i do have a pithy
answer and i want to unpack it with you
and then i want to hear what you have to
say so
here's my my pithy answer searching for
pros
and quotes tethers us to the cons
and so i think that it's okay to
to learn the negative and positive
lessons from yesteryear
but i find that whenever i take a piece
of paper out and make the line down the
middle here's the pros
on this side and here's the cons
it's an intellectual exercise but it
doesn't really help with a deeper
understanding
of our nature and
um and so i think in these situations
because they're so complex it's not like
do i want to buy the honda accord or the
toyota camry okay the pro con list
probably going to help out with that
even then you probably know which one
you want and the pro con list is
irrelevant
yeah and i think the same thing might be
true with our living situations
you've been told you've been prescribed
here's what you must do
at age 22 you're supposed to get married
and you have three and a half kids and a
dog and a cat and you live in this house
and a
yard and a fence nothing wrong with any
of those things
they're not going to make you happy
they're externalities
happiness and peace are only uncovered
right
and so you asked a moment ago what is
enough
maybe if i were to pin that i would say
well what is appropriate
for your life for your preferences
and it seems to me that like chris the
situation you're in i would not like
that at
all now it's not because i think it's
wrong
i think that i spend most of my time
alone so i think that being around more
people
is going to decrease my tranquility in a
way
yeah that's a weird perspective isn't it
i think so and you know weird is
actually an acronym here
yes westernize educated industrialized
rich
and democratic there's a really good
book called the weirdest people in the
world by joe henrik
where he writes about this phenomena
and includes um the big five personality
traits introversion is one of them
and it's unique to weird societies
yes so the us canada the uk
australia new zealand these are all
weird places right right
and introversion does not exist in
hunter gatherers it just doesn't make
any sense if you think
fierce egalitarian if your existence
depends on sharing
right the best place to store food is in
the belly of my brother
yes then where does introversion fit
into that
it doesn't and when they go examine
hunter-gatherers and ask them
questions that should identify these big
five
personality traits they don't find them
but what about
so the most enlightened people in
history have all
gone off we can take away the terms
introvert and extrovert for the sake of
this and had
large stretches of solitude now
that could be because they're trying to
beat the culture out of them
right that was that that ruined the
hunter-gatherer nature
and and so the buddha for example had
you know to go off for seven years
supposedly eating
a grain of rice a day or something
absurd right um
and and in doing the
that stillness the solitude the the the
alone
time um it almost was like a
deprogramming of
of the culture in a way or of society um
yeah i really like cal newport's
definition of solitude i know you know
him i've heard him on the podcast i
interviewed him too
yeah and you remember him talking about
solitude as a state that you can achieve
anywhere right you can have solitude in
a coffee shop working surrounded by
people and noise
yeah it's the absence of input from
another human mind which ultimately is
your choice right so
you can still have solitude in my
chaotic living room with a bunch of
kids bouncing around between the walls
right if
if you choose not to get tugged around
by every input that comes your way so i
think it's a choice i think you can
still have
solitude in a noisy environment yeah i
totally agree with that i call it
ambient people like i like to write in
coffee shops quite often
yeah but i where i disagree is like you
can but you can't if
people are demanding your attention and
so if i am saying hey ryan ryan
ryan right and he's trying to be in
solitude he's either gonna have to be a
total jerk
to me but i'm really the one being the
jerk because i'm constantly you know
ryan ryan ryan but like him not
reciprocating
that is actually going to hurt our
relationship and so that's what i'm
talking when i talk about boundaries
even
like figuring out what is appropriate in
in my life and so yeah i i i have a
unusual living arrangement you know uh
my wife and i have
you know separate places in separate
states and we spend every other week
apart
and in in doing that it's the most ideal
scenario for
us given our current constraints um
however uh if if i was forced into
your situation could i i could could i
make it work yeah i could but i don't
know that it would be optimal for me and
i think that's the difference yeah i
wouldn't deny that again it's like
choosing people that share that value
system like you're probably a bunch of
introverts are probably
not going to work together but there is
also an economy of scale there so
imagine you've got a bunch of kids it's
like really hard for you to have alone
time
but if the kids are all happy together i
mean i can look after
five kids as easy as i can look after
two kids and so maybe
in the end you end up with more alone
time like you can go off and take a walk
and do whatever you want to do because
i'm there to take care of your kids and
actually it makes my life easier when
there are more kids yeah
i think that's kind of a sense yeah sort
of paradox there you know like it seems
like you're getting less
time alone but in the end you will end
up with more because i know right now
like with having just one kid
and we don't even have her full time
right it but when we have her it's two
parents parenting parenting
one child parenting the activity not the
relationship
yeah yeah it's like we're just uh and so
it's
it's a strange it's a strange thing
because if
she had more siblings then it would i
think
it would actually ease oh totally yeah
so you know about this so having
multiple kids
as you're finding as you're going
through these living situations
is there anything that is that you found
to be your sweet spot that you think is
applicable to other people
between how many people you're living on
the same sort of commune with
um i honestly don't know the answer to
that yet yeah we've been doing what are
we doing
is it big is it 20 people is it 40
people yeah i suspect that once you get
to a certain number
you then start having problems with
communication you know that
it then becomes like a sort of you know
you have to have like democratic
processes and stuff
keeping everybody on the same page i can
imagine that would start to become
inefficient
but yeah we've not found enough p i mean
that's part of the reason why i'm here
today is to try and find some more
like-minded people
well they how do they how do they find
you oh well you can find me my email
address chris at nourishbalancedrive.com
uh-oh
be careful what you asked for chris i'm
moving to santa cruz
let's see so so back to eric's questions
here when we're talking about
you know and obviously on the maximum
episode we'll talk more about we have a
whole article about throuples
uh combined families long-term
singlehood as well
nomadic living uh and so what you're
doing isn't
nomadic living um because you're in one
place
we're still sedentary right but it is
from our societal standpoint it's it's
it's semi-nomadic in a way meaning
you're not tethered to that place you
know
you're not commuting to the same job
every day etc even though you have a
career you can do that from pretty much
anywhere
yeah no we would be totally happy to
move somewhere else for the right
opportunity
and maybe that's the right thing to do
that's the problem we've got right now
is california is so ridiculously
expensive
that maybe we just need to find a you
know plot of land in
texas or colorado or something like that
you know where it's all montana actually
would probably be a good option where
it's so much cheaper
yeah yeah although it's it's very cold
there in there i know i know that's why
everyone wants to live in california
it's sunny and nice and
yeah it's great yeah yes indeed it's
like florida's got summer
year-round but the humidity that's that
that that's the thing that keeps people
away from florida
summer in florida man yeah so ryan i'm
looking here at eric's question
how happy are these people in these
arrangements again i think this is
this is highly individual right yes and
that's why i don't
think there is a supposed not that i
think there is no supposed to we were
not
born to live in a nuclear family but
it's not wrong to live in a nuclear
family
either it may be the most appropriate
thing for you
but instead of here's the problem i have
chris
is is we we often feel
i'm supposed to do this thing
right because society and culture has
has convinced me it's it's the
quote-unquote right thing
to do but now i'm feeling discontented
by it and it's not that
well i'm saying you shouldn't do the
thing that society's telling you to do
it's that knowing that you're better
you're better off
if you know that it's not the thing that
you have to do
and therefore if you do decide to
intentionally embark on a
nuclear family and you have the american
dream or whatever and you
you're contented by that great but
it's not um it's not the prescription
what is the prescription of the catholic
church it depends i mean so i think
that's important to understand where
this came from
that's what joe henrich wrote about in
his book is that the monogamous nuclear
family is an invention of the catholic
church
in the fourth century and it was the
best money-making system ever
right you couldn't get divorced you
couldn't adopt a child
you could only pass on your money to
your son and heir
yeah i mean just biologically speaking
at some point you're not going to
produce a sun in air
right and if you don't produce sun and
air it all goes to the tree it all goes
to the church and
you know at some point the the catholic
church end up owning
you know like a third of germany it was
like the best business model ever
wow and so that's where it originates
that's where the idea originates and so
i mean if
you don't really subscribe to the ideas
but not by the catholic church and the
protestants weren't much better they
just kind of
you know took it to its streams but joe
henrik writes about that history in his
book so i'd recommend that
now you're not saying that no one was
monogamous
previous to that you're saying it was
not the default
setting of the culture at the time no i
don't think anyone was monogamous before
that and i think that
even to this day like this the idea that
you know the monogamous
family is um unique to weird societies
right there are still
places um around today where they don't
do like cousin marriage is really common
you know that
polygamy is still a thing like it's not
it's only we don't know because we're
inside of this bubble and we can't
really see out
yeah but i mean there's definitely gonna
be people listening to this that's like
yeah of course
like this monogamous nuclear family
thing why would you do that stupid
yeah yeah what interesting
it's funny though because i don't think
that this is where i push back i don't
see it as stupid
but maybe this is just my acculturation
like that i've been
i've been forced to think it's not it
that it's not stupid i don't think it's
stupid or not stupid
yeah i think it's it's
there's a reason that we've continued to
do it for a
prolonged period of time right now
it may not work for the average person
listen to this or it might work for you
and so it it's hard for me to to say
that
it's stupid because i
i kind of do feel that in a way yeah
like there's something in me where i'm
like yeah
let me let me substitute the word stupid
with species appropriate
you know going back to my human zoo you
wouldn't keep the penguins on hot sand
and you don't keep the humans in
monogamous nuclear families right like
that's what i'm arguing it's not species
appropriate i mean there is an upside to
it
the upside when joe henrik writes about
that is economic prosperity
is you get people who are strangers to
cooperate in ways that they wouldn't
otherwise
because the alternative like a kin-based
arrangement it's like all nepotism right
like all the
you know like all your business goes to
someone who's family like that's how
that's the alternative
right and and that's why the monogamous
nuclear family has become
so prevalent today is because of the
economic prosperity which is the upside
right so ryan you anything pithy for us
yeah uh you know listening to eric's
question i think
you know maybe he's looking at different
examples
because maybe he i don't know i'm just
assuming that maybe he feels
that the way he wants to live uh with
his family maybe it's a little
weird um but yeah i mean my pithy answer
is a genuine life doesn't require
someone else's approval so when i think
about your
um your uh uh not extra virgin but
introversion
like that is strange to me but it's not
strange to you
that's you living a genuine life so
because of that
you know josh isn't looking for external
approval from other people to be like
well is it okay
that that i'm alone um although i i did
do that for the longest time and it made
me miserable
oh yeah it absolutely did especially
during like the corporate days for sure
but you know i look at this question the
last one about the pros and cons
and we could sit here and maybe we put
together a nice pros and cons list for
eric here
right but there would be our pros and
cons
that's a great point and by the way
what's usual for you could be unusual
for me yeah some people's pros or other
people's cons
i also wrote down here unusual is
usually ideal so chris lives in an
unusual situation because he's done so
deliberately right
it's intentional exactly rather than
just choosing the societal right
right default instead of charging the uh
decided on the usual thing right
accepting the usual thing
you've done something quote unquote
unusual right
and and that's what's appropriate for
you bex and i have done something that
is
unusual meaning it's not it doesn't
conform exactly to the societal
standards it's
it there's a venn diagram but there's
even a venn diagram with you
and and you have a wife right that's a
that's a relic of your past right and if
you right
she might have something to say about
that i mean that's the thing though
right like
we you were told that you needed to be
married at some point right
but you hunter gatherers never married
right that's that's another
interesting point actually that that joe
henrich argues that what came before
monogamy was
polygamy and i had an interesting
conversation with our mutual friend
chris ryan about that
and uh you know sort of the short answer
is that it really depends how you define
marriage so for some hunter-gatherer
bands or even you know indigenous people
um
they define marriages like if i hang my
hammock next to yours and we spend the
night together then we're married and
then if i take my hammock somewhere else
then
we're not married anymore right so it
really depends like the literature is
really hard to
to interpret because it really depends
on how you define marriage it's like a
really slippery thing to define
yeah no i totally agree yeah ryan and i
call our significant others our
our wives but we don't have a piece of
paper that says
that we are oh really yeah yeah that's
interesting it's because i don't
i don't want to get the government
involved in our love and and so like
there's bex feels the same way
thankfully i know ryan is on on the same
page but like
it has a lot to do with you how do you
define marriage
i don't define it as government
involvement by the way like
even our government people early on
george washington didn't have a
government certificate for his marriage
but he was
married i find that monogamy works
really well
in bexa's in my relationship however
we have actually i'm going to save this
for the maximal because
we're going to get kind of private here
so we'll save that for
the private pockets we've got a bunch
more questions as well also uh
i do have a a communal living themed
added value
this week all right but uh we got some
listener comments and tips as well
and a bunch more surprise questions like
what are some examples
of successful nomads how about
successful throuples and long-term
single people don't most societies
treat the hoarding of things from past
generations things like
sentimental heirlooms as a net positive
so we have someone arguing for
hoarding um and then what
what have been the unexpected upsides
and downsides of communal living for
chris we've touched on a few of those
but i really do want to i want to get
honest about
what uh what lessons you've learned
there plus a million more questions
about
unusual living situations and if you
want to hear all that listen to this
week's
maximal episode on patreon that's right
you're currently listening to our weekly
minimal episode but each thursday ryan
and i and our guest we record a much
longer maximal episode
for the minimalist private podcast visit
theminimalists.com
support to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our private
podcast plays in your favorite podcast
app
if you enjoy our show and want to
support the minimalist this is the only
way our podcast earns money it's cheaper
than a cup of coffee and it keeps our
show 100
advertisement free plus private private
podcast subscribers also gain access to
hundreds of hours of archives ryan what
else you got for us this week here are
some voicemail
comments and insights from our listeners
check them out hey y'all
this is emily stewart from florence
south carolina and i wanted to share a
tip
so i've been a minimalist my entire life
even as a kid but i find
myself thinking that i don't have
anything to get rid of because i'm a
minimalist
so i came up with a game with myself
that kind of helps me
to keep cleaning things out i often
shop at trader joe's and aldi's and i
bring my own bags
but sometimes i forget and end up having
to grab the paper bags at checkout
so my new rule for myself is every time
i do this
i have to fill up the paper bags with
things from my home to give away or sell
so although for getting my own bags
isn't good for the environment it turned
into a great way to consistently clear
out
and help keep it fun for me and fresh
even though i am have been a minimalist
for so long
mary rose coughlin vernon connecticut um
so
that's happened to me several times or
i've lost a great deal of money
in a pocket that i gave away or tipping
from the wrong
pocket when i had money traveling and
i like to think that that person needed
the money more than i did
so whether you say god wanted them to
have it or
the power of the universe knew they
needed it
that person needed the money more than
you did and you're blessed to have an
opportunity to share it with them
all right y'all for our added value this
week you talked about you saw this um
chris you saw um what's the name of the
wawa country
right yeah so there's another
docu-series
about nexium have you heard about nexium
no i can't wait to watch this this is
great
yeah i'm like fascinated by the cult
documentaries that they do or even the
um
oh man the one that the reenactment one
they did the series
with uh the waco one yeah with waco oh
yeah
tyler kitsch was his name he played uh
david koresh that was so good
all right so tell us about next i i too
am fascinating here's why i'm fascinated
by this because
i am often fascinated on the trajectory
of where you are right now where you
have two three four families living on
the same land
with kids whatever and then also
where's the tipping point where it
becomes a cult
all that chris is missing is a guru
exactly
that's the thing right like if you keep
it egalitarian then
it can't be a cult the moment you have a
guru like then you're in trouble
yes yeah and but also
aren't there there are like great gurus
who have no interest in forming a cult
whatsoever like they don't want
yeah you know they they just want to be
teachers or whatever maybe that's the
difference
they call themselves teachers or masters
it's wild how it always starts
with usually something positive like so
mariah
has been reading a book and i i don't
know what the name of it is
but she was like you should really check
out this book it talks about this guy
named osho oh wow
and she's like and she's going on and on
and i'm like i'm like that rings a bell
like where have i heard the name before
and then she's like oh my god she's like
i've been reading this wild wild country
guys
book and i had no idea until she like
got three quarters of the way through it
and she was like oh wow this is that
wild wild
country guy it does seem that osho was
probably an enlightened person but also
had
just some sort of weird fascinating
fascination with material he was a
narcissist wasn't he was
my understanding yeah maybe i don't know
i mean i
i or maybe he had no ego at all like i
don't know what that looks like
i think he it doesn't even matter i mean
personally i think he trusted the wrong
people
and he did yes why was he driving all of
these i mean
there's nothing wrong with rolls-royce i
don't think he did anything wrong no i
also think he had a lot of wisdom
and so the book she read pro i've i
haven't read a lot of his stuff she's
been sharing some of the wisdom and i'm
like oh that is a pretty awesome insight
yeah that's pretty great i mean he had a
ton of insights
yeah and i but i think you know uh you
know absolute power corrupts absolutely
so i mean maybe that's the point he got
to but i know like with when i saw wild
wild country i was like oh like osho
got to a point where he kind of like put
his hands in the air
and let everyone else around him run
everything yeah
and maybe that's where it started to go
wrong when he stopped
you know trying when he you know reached
nirvana he was like all right i'm here
and
i don't really care what happens around
me yeah i guess would be it could be
yeah
and someone else stepped up and was
power hungry and yeah
and so there was power struggling but
even like david koresh i mean like
watching that
docu-series like it started out where he
was
you know helping people i mean he was a
little insane
um but i guess we're all a little insane
you know just it's the level of uh how
insane are we
well i don't know chris maybe we could
talk about that you've got
you have a this this these cults
and the commonality in fact the line
from oh by the way my added value this
week is called the vowel
vow the vowel uh and it
is a docu-series on hbo about nex the
nexium
cult and the thing that you
you learn is i think two things sort of
converge whenever one of these cults
forms
one is you have some sort of brilliant
ideas
wisdom insights etc at least the most
compelling ones that's how they get
people to join
because there's some sort of brilliant
insight there right and then you have
kooky beliefs
that are sort of mixed in with that
right yeah and so
the david koresh thing is a great
example of you know kooky believes
because eventually he's like well
god has told me that only i oh i can
have sex with the women in our tribe
and and the men must be monogamous and
or they must be celibate rather and it
becomes very
strange very quickly yeah it's weird how
it starts with some type of
like good intention and with like a deep
truth that gets uncovered but then it
gets mixed with all this belief yeah the
craziness yeah
and so chris nobody joins a cult is the
l one of the lines
in this in this uh docuseries i love
that and that's true right like it's a
guy who's in the cult who's right
no and he's he's found out like oh i've
gone too far i've got to get out
whatever
and he says but no one joins a cult
right
you don't you'll never be anyone who's
looking to sign up for a cult right
and yet lots of people join colts yeah
because they don't realize
in fact maybe the time they joined it it
wasn't yet a cult oh man
and so um we talked about how do we
avoid that but also
um i'm just fascinated because parts of
this
are so good and human and nourishing and
there are spiritual components and all
of this
and then it's always tainted by
something else
an abusive power yeah i mean the desire
to belong is is so strong isn't it it's
not surprising that
people are drawn into that sort of thing
i mean even in wild wild country did you
not
i mean especially the early episodes did
you not look at that and think
wow that looks awesome i like to go
there definitely a part of it look
really really good and then it all
started the wheels came off the wagon
eventually right but in the beginning it
looks great right
the whole concept was we're going to
have a community to like show how
a community can thrive and yeah and they
and they did a very good job of that in
the beginning yeah i totally agree
and so i don't know maybe the key is
that you keep it below a certain
threshold and
it can't be a cult as long as there's
fewer than 10 people like i don't know
what
what it is but that's certainly
something that we want to avoid right
uh real quick for right here right now
here's one thing that's going on in the
life of the minimalist we have a new
book coming out
nourish balance thrive is actually
mentioned in it briefly oh thank you
it's called love people use things you
can pre-order it really helps us out if
you do pre-order it
the print book the e-book or the
audiobook over at
lovepeopleusethings.net you can also see
the beautiful trailer
that jordan put together for the book
it's called love people use things it'll
be out this summer
but you can pre-order it now help us out
a lot lovepeopleusthings.net you can
follow the minimalists on facebook
twitter and instagram
at the minimalist chris what are you on
social media we don't really do social
media
i sort of gave up on that after cal news
what a hipster
that's great man welcome to one of our
live podcast shows visit
theminimalists.com tour to find a city
near you you can
find chris over at
nourishbalancethrive.com and apparently
you can email him
chris at chris nourishbalancethrive.com
if you have a question comment or
minimalism tip for our podcast email a
voice memo
to podcasts at theminimalists.com
comment on this episode youtube.com
slash the minimalist and if you want our
show notes in your inbox
sign up for our email list over at the
minimalists.com you'll also receive our
simple sunday emails and if you leave
here today with just one message
we hope it's this love people and use
things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time
[Music]
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it